do you believe that there is life out
there in like another universe um
yes with a question mark
demi lovato definitely does and i talked
to demi all about their alien encounter
living my life so i go to heaven and
never come back i had a weird experience
and i don't really know what to call it
i basically i felt like i was visited by
some beings in my room
and then um
yeah and then i i traveled it was this
bright light it kind of moved in like
these weird
ways demi claims they were taken by
alien beings while on a trip to joshua
tree the 29 year old singer says they
went willingly and communicated
telepathically with the beings they call
their light doctors i feel like we're
all our own worst enemy or at least i am
and
so i i definitely
could see
how if anything is up there watching
over me they're definitely trying to
protect me from my worst enemy images
myself can you at least say hello to
demi
the shocking revelation is made in
demi's four-part docu-series
unidentified with demi lovato streaming
on peacock the series includes demi's
sister dallas and best friend matthew
montgomery together they investigate
abduction stories and talk to ufo
experts demi even undergoes hypnosis to
recall their own experience where do you
fall on the belief skepticism the whole
thing i have a very open mind you know
but this was this was unlike anything
that i've ever experienced yes before we
shot the show i was a skeptic and now
since we've shot it i haven't stopped
talking about it what if they're already
here waiting for us to reach out
you're not gonna take this away from me
jamie foxx reprising his villainous role
as electro in spiderman no way home love
it you know home really is where the
heart is for jamie because he talks all
about being a dad and dad life in his
book act like you got some sense which
is all about the trials and tribulations
of raising two daughters in the
hollywood limelight
[Music]
there was a real struggle in your life
between a party jamie foxx then the
family jamie foxx i remember taking
career to a party when it was she was
13. she's like dad i'm not supposed to
be here
so what i did learn to do was
invite them let them see what the dad
was doing because my daughter benefited
from her uncle being leonardo dicaprio
and then my youngest daughter rihanna
pinching her cheeks and
and what it did was it allowed them to
see the artist it sort of worked out
it's been bring your daughter to work
and sometimes to the party for jamie's
girls 27 year old corrine and 13 year
old annalise but the oscar winner told
me that along with the joys he's been
through an awful lot of pain as a single
dad i was a disney dad and didn't know i
was out running trying to make sure
everything was great but i was missing
time so when i show up let's just go to
disneyland let mickey mouse fix anything
the emotional potholes will just fill it
with mickey mouse and at one point we
end up in front of a therapist and my
daughter told me hey i really like you
she said hear me out to disneyland and
all those things was great but all i
wanted i just really wanted to kick you
with you
jamie gets real in his book act like you
got some sense that is what his late
grandmother estelle always used to tell
him she was fiercely protective and
would pull a gun on anyone who dared
mess with jamie tyler perry everybody
seen my dear
my grandmother was first my dick you
better back the hell up out of my face
i'm crying outside my girl what what's
wrong with you
and it's that cry
who did what she said come on we're
gonna walk down to the house
where this just went down she recently
moved she pulled out 38 knocked on the
door i said oh my god the people that
answered the door she stuck the gun and
said listen
this boy special okay
he going places i don't want to have to
come back in here with this 38 i have to
fire it just made me feel like man she's
willing to walk through any door to make
sure
i have what i need
to flourish so i can't mess it up
[Music]
that is a man who is a great father and
the most authentic person you'll ever
meet ever he's so funny all right
vanessa lachey is another parent sharing
life lessons and new traditions in her
new book life from scratch now vanessa
talked to me all about loss and finding
love with soul mate nick lachey in
another e.t exclusive
i'm still in love with him but i'm
different i'm a different in love than i
was 15 years yeah of course and i'm
probably going to be a different in love
15 years from now seeing him now as a
father to our three kids but then when
i'm going to see him as a father to our
teenagers and then see him as a father
or as a grandfather come on driving the
rv
going across the country
that's sexy
yeah we can totally see grandpa nick
rocking an rv but for now he's content
living that island life after vanessa
landed the lead role on ncis hawaii i
just asked him to pick up and move to
hawaii well
to move to hawaii
you know i didn't have to twist his arm
too much but if i'm being completely
real that's a lot it's a big ask and
it's been a lot for our family to
transition um he's left everything
willingly and supportively everything to
come support me now and that's not all
vanessa credits nick with helping her
heal from a painful childhood her mom
left when she was just nine years old i
look at these kids and and camden is the
age when my mom left and i'm like
there is not a bone an ounce
in my body that could ever just walk
away from you so
i don't understand it have you made your
piece with your mom
yes and no i've made the piece that i
need to make to be able to speak about
it but i would be lying if i said it
doesn't still
bother me what happened because she was
such the best mom until she left but
ultimately i said instead of saying woe
is me and i didn't have a great mother
example in my life what can i do to be
that for my kids how can i break that
cycle
part of breaking the cycle is forming
new traditions that will strengthen the
bond with nick and her kids
one of the stories you told was about
the cartier love
bracelet
yeah i was thinking i wanted it to have
it forever as a symbol of us and when we
had our daughter and when he put it on
me he said
i have to screw this on you with this
tool and so it stays on forever until
you unscrew it and i said wow that's
beautiful and then he took it a step
further
and said when our daughter is eighteen
we screw it on her wrist together so she
can have a piece of us don't you cry and
i was nine months pregnant and i was
like
this is right and that's what it's about
it's um it's see now you're gonna be i
know i'm sorry i'm sorry it's very very
sweet
um yeah that's what it's about before we
go one more star confession that many
parents have an opinion on the great
bathing debate of 2021. ashton kutcher
mila kunis started it all when they said
they only wash their kids when they can
see dirt on them
hollywood had a field day with this one
and lauren zema got mila's hot or cold
tape for everybody bye guys go back get
some washcloths oh lord just come on
yeah scrub
i'm sure you're you're sick of talking
about the bath debate
i mean i'm now literally gonna be like
no comment
if you can see the dirt on them clean
them yeah otherwise there's no point if
you want to go a couple days without it
great if you have bad hygiene that's not
on me and if i have been a hygiene i'm
gonna go ahead and be honest with you
it's not your business
were you surprised by the reaction how
many people weighed in like cardi b
weighed in the rock waited i don't think
i'm aware of how many people weighed in
when this
storm hit bleep it out if you must but
it's great listen if it gets people's
mind off of reality who cares